ich finde man muss hier an der Stelle
auch mal den Blick etwas weiten im Bezug
auf die Frage wie beendet man denn die
Kriege und ich bin der Auffassung dass
der Krieg in der Ukraine auf
militärischenem Wege nicht beendet
werden kann sondern dass er auf
diplomatischen Wege beendet werden wird
und auch muss und ich möchte auch meinen
Blick werfen nach Israel es ist ja
gerade auch davon gesprochen worden von
der Resolution und von der Frage dass
Deutschland jetzt unverbrüchlich an
Israel Seite steht weil man da sagt man
liefert alles ich halte das für einen
irglauben anzunehmen dass man den
Konflikt im nosten militärisch lösen
kann als wenn sozusagen wenn man die
Hamas im Gaza vernichten könnte ich
glaube das funktioniert nicht es seid
man würde den Gasastreifen im Erdboden
gleich machen das kann ja nicht das Ziel
sein sondern es ist ja anders man kann
das nur lösen indem man sagt wir
brauchen einen einen echten Weg zu einer
Zweistaatenlösung das heißt die
militärische Unterstützung wird das
Problem an der Stelle
überhaupt